en este vídeo me gustaría realizar un
repaso de lo que hemos aprendido acerca
de los monopolios y durante el proceso
ir obteniendo mejor entendimiento por
algunas representaciones gráficas que
voy a realizar y bueno en el pasado
habíamos hablado como de varios temas
acerca del monopolio pero en este vídeo
quiero juntarlos así que digamos que en
la industria en la que estamos dentro
esta sería la curva de demanda que
luciría como algo así entonces voy a
asumir que esta demanda o dicha demanda
es como una curva lineal y este eje de
por acá nos va a representar dólares por
unidad en el contexto de la demanda es
el precio y lo que tenemos por acá va a
ser la cantidad y en esta pequeña
gráfica de por acá abajo en el eje
horizontal vamos a tener también la
cantidad pero en cuanto al eje vertical
no solo vamos a hablar
de dólares por unidad sino del valor
absoluto en cuanto al nivel de dólares
que tengamos y me gustaría que quedara
un tanto obvio que nosotros somos los
únicos productores dado que somos un
monopolio estamos hablando de un
monopolio nosotros tenemos un monopolio
en el mercado así que nosotros
recogeríamos la cantidad
y si no producimos nada no tendríamos
ningún tipo de ganancia y por dicha
razón estoy poniendo aquí estos puntos
en cero entonces también por otro lado
tenemos que si nosotros producimos
demasiado pero no estamos generando nos
nada entonces también el punto ya por
aquí en cero nuestros ingresos también
serían cero y bueno lo explicado en otro
vídeo anterior que conforme nosotros
incrementamos nuestra cantidad es este
punto en cuanto más grande sea los
ingresos irá creciendo y creciendo lo
suficiente a tal punto en que llegue a
un máximo y después vendrán ahora hacia
abajo por lo que nuestra curva de
ingresos luciría algo así en nuestros
ingresos totales lucen justo así y bueno
esto es en cuanto a términos de ingresos
totales pero también podríamos pensar
cómo lucirían los ingresos marginales
recordando que dichos ingresos
marginales simplemente nos dicen cómo
vamos incrementando nuestra cantidad
poco a poco o cómo va incrementando los
ingresos totales de una forma gradual y
esto es esencialmente que nos marca la
pendiente de los ingresos totales y
cuando me refiero
qué quiere decir cómo ir trazando la
curva a punto por punto es decir una
recta tangente a dicha curva y aquí como
te darás cuenta la pendiente se va
trazando como de una forma positiva y
llega un punto en el que se intersecta
justo por aquí y esto va manteniendo la
pendiente cada vez más hacia abajo
provocando que sea más intensa y esto se
convierte en una pendiente negativa por
lo que entonces aquí había cruzado el
punto cero y hacia abajo es lo negativo
y justo fue la representación de
nuestros ingresos marginales pero yendo
ahora la ganancia máxima nosotros
tenemos que pensar en cómo están
actuando o están luciendo nuestros
costos entonces déjame dibujar nuestros
costos totales es hora de dibujar
nuestros costos totales y esta será la
curva que los estaría representando y si
observas esta curva de nuestros costos
totales no inicia en cero lo que nos
quiere decir es que en varios años hubo
cero unidades que todos nuestros costos
estuvieron fijados
pero que después se tuvo que producir
más y más unidades en un costo variable
que está moviéndose por acá incluso en
este diagrama podemos comenzar a
visualizar la ganancia económica la
ganancia económica que estamos hablando
en cuanto a costos y ganancias y el
hablar o enfatizar deberíamos visualizar
que estos términos de ganancias
económicas están hablando de los costos
totales de los costos totales de
oportunidad así es costos totales de
oportunidad los cuales implícita o
explícitamente en algún momento todos
los hemos llegado a pagar donde nos
vamos a ver reflejados sobre el ingreso
total será la diferencia que hay entre
los ingresos totales y los costos
totales de oportunidad que nos dan la
ganancia económica esta barrita de aquí
es la que nos está representando dicha
diferencia que al final nos está
representando la cantidad que tenemos
por acá y la ganancia económica es la
altura de dicha barra pero como nosotros
vivimos conforme nosotros incrementamos
estas cantidades por aquí estas curvas
se van a ir como separando
y esto se debe a que la curva verde la
de los ingresos totales tiene una
pendiente un poco más larga o convexa
respecto a la púrpura que ésta nos
representa los costos totales de
oportunidad entonces nosotros podemos
incluso a través de estas dos curvas ir
obteniendo grandes diferencias y aquí
podemos observar que luce como un máximo
y que queda fuera de la razón y este es
el comportamiento que va llevando dicho
máximo aquí lo voy a recalcar como para
que se alcanza a ver un poco más y su
comportamiento es así y si te das cuenta
más adelante luego las curvas otra vez
comienzan a acercarse y la curva púrpura
ahora es un poco más larga que las
pendientes que son de color naranja y
ahora le observan entonces estas dos
simples gráficas lo que podemos ver es
que cualquiera de las máximas distancias
entre estas dos curvas luce como lo
estoy mostrando justo aquí entonces
nosotros vimos que esto fue un máximo en
la ganancia económica y también podemos
nosotros visualizarlo en la curva de por
acá
en la gráfica de por acá entonces
podemos realizar esto trazando un costo
trazando un costo marginal y debemos
recordar que como cuando hicimos
nosotros los ingresos marginales estos
eran de las pendientes que salían de
dichos ingresos totales entonces en este
caso se dan como las pendientes pero
hablando de los costos totales y así es
como nos queda nuestra curva de costos
marginales y la curva marginal en
nuestra gráfica de por acá abajo la voy
a reflejar con puntos amarillos que nos
nos van a ir reflejando dichas
pendientes y entonces por aquí tenemos
una pendiente igual o casi cercana a
cero que es la idea del trazo de por
aquí entonces tu costo marginal va a
estar cercano también al cero por acá y
después nosotros veamos que la pendiente
va a ir incrementando e incrementando e
incrementando y entonces en un costo
marginal se verá reflejado dicho
incremento
así que si tomamos una cantidad y luego
buscamos su costo marginal por aquí no
sé
qué les parece cinco dólares cinco
dólares por unidad esto literalmente
significa que la pendiente a esta misma
cantidad la pendiente de nuestra curva
de costo total la pendiente en esto será
o tendrá un valor de 5 y tiene sentido
antes de este punto nuestros ingresos
marginales son más altos que los costos
marginales lo que significa que la
pendiente de las curvas de ingresos
totales es más larga que la pendiente de
la curva de costos totales por lo que
estás cada vez están más apartadas y
después justo en el punto la pendiente
es la misma por lo que la pendiente va a
ser la misma acá y después de ese dicho
punto la pendiente de la curva del costo
marginal donde el costo marginal bueno
yo estaba antes del punto hablando en
cuanto a la curva del costo total perdón
pero es más alta que la pendiente de los
ingresos totales y esto será como
realmente cada vez más cercanas se van
dando estas distancias entonces lo que
esto nos está diciendo es que si
trazamos una app en día
la curva que está por aquí y queremos
maximizar la ganancia tenemos que
visualizar cómo se comportaría la curva
y bien si nosotros produjéramos desde un
inicio desde la nada empezamos a
producir entonces dicho incremento por
unidad se estaría marcando respecto al
incremento que estamos teniendo el
ingreso estaría respecto al incremento
entonces nosotros deberíamos de producir
pues las ganancias que irían con
nosotros y así podríamos seguir y seguir
haciéndolo seguir produciendo hasta que
el ingreso marginal fuera igual al costo
marginal en ese punto no tendría sentido
para nosotros producir aún más porque si
produjéramos unidades extras ese pasando
a dicho de dicho punto nuestros costos
entonces se elevarían más que nuestros
ingresos y bueno justo la curva que
acabo de dibujar representa un trazo del
promedio de la curva de costos totales
donde esencialmente lo que estamos
realizando con ella es tomar la curva de
costos totales e irla distinguiendo de
la pendiente en cualquier punto
es el costo marginal y es decir solo
estamos dividiendo por pequeñas
cantidades por lo que si tomas esto como
la curva de costos totales y te vamos
tomando cada valor separándolos o
dividiendo los por pequeñas cantidades
es justo lo que está representando aquí
y justo este punto que acabamos de
marcar por aquí es el precio que se
obtendría con dicha cantidad pero habrá
que visualizar que el precio sería igual
a los ingresos a los ingresos sobre
unidad y por dichas bases unitarias esto
es el costo en medio es tu costo
promedio que lo que hace es tomar todos
tus costos y dividirlo entre las
unidades entonces dicho promedio por las
bases de unidad va a ser tu ganancia
económica y también por las bases de
unidad si quieres encontrar tu ganancia
económica lo que tendríamos que hacer es
multiplicar por el número total de
unidades por lo que esencialmente tienes
el área de este rectángulo que está por
aquí dibujado del color amarillo que
sería el promedio de la ganancia
económica y la ganancia económica total
será la cantidad por la ganancia x
y entonces lo que escribimos por aquí es
la ganancia sería la ganancia económica
que al recibirlo será la total la
ganancia económica total y el área de
dicho rectángulo deberá de ser la misma
cosa que la altura de la gráfica que
tenemos por acá abajo y la otra razón
con la que podemos mantener que este es
el escenario sustentable esto es porque
hablamos de un monopolio entonces aquí
no hay ningún tipo de barrera y otra
gente diría hey esta ganancia económica
es un incentivo para que ocupe sus
recursos y trates de competir por un
puesto y dar un mejor regreso de mis
costos de oportunidad y sería otra forma
de pensarlo una alternativa de verlo